[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Hey there. Welcome back to the
homestead. Today we are working on the
offgrid um garden watering setup. Uh
what I got here is a 1100galon water
tank, a pair of tennis shoes and a can
of glue and some plumbing fittings along
with pipe. And um what we're working on
is on the top of this hill here is a
irrigation ditch. It's a part of a large
network of irrigation ditches throughout
the foothills of Northern California
here. And uh it runs right through the
property, which is really nice. Uh one
thing that we don't have is power. There
is power lines right there, but I don't
have a meter and a pole on this lower
portion of property. So, we're just
doing with what we got the uh most
cheapest way and and see if we can make
it work. Uh so, what I'm going to work
on is getting water from the there's a
valve there that they supply. I'm going
to have it tied into the top side here.
And then on the bottom, I'm just going
to do a couple valves that will uh allow
us to get water to that direction. and
it's I just want to have a stockpile of
water. Um, we'll go over how the the
ditch works and all that and sizing of
water and stuff like that. It'll kind of
explain why I got a tank. Um, so yeah,
what I'm going to do, put it all
together and then we'll kind of walk
through it and I'll just show you what I
did and uh hopefully it works. Let's get
started.
[Music]
So, some people might ask to prime or
not to prime. That's what this purple
stuff is. It's a PVC primer. When I was
younger, uh, working on a VA hospital
and, uh, we did a chiller bypass system
and we were doing 8 in PVC, 8 and 6 in
PVC, and, uh, you bet you, we primed cuz
we did not want any failures in any way.
Um, yeah, it was uh, something else. So,
yeah, we'd prime it and then put glue
and then slam them together. We actually
had to use ratchet straps to like pull
it together. It was it was uh crazy. And
some of them were like 50 ft in the air.
It was just uh it was fun. So, we got uh
all our fittings or all our pipes here.
I'm leaving this one a little bit long
in case I do run into any issues. I'm
able to cut this and either put a
coupling or a union in there. But, yeah,
I just like to be safe and prepared for
the future. Now, I'm going to start
gluing it up.
[Music]
Another good tip to have is uh when
you're gluing up your fittings, glue
your female fitting first and that way
you can set it down
and then uh
do the male fitting because this one's a
little bit harder to set down with glue
on the outside. So, just uh keep that
one on your mind.
And then also uh push and hold. Don't
let off right away because it will kind
of work its way out.
[Music]
Come on. Come on.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
All
right. Well, I should probably do the
right thing and let it sit for a little
while before I turn it on,
but
that's not going to happen. I'm going to
give it a try. It's not under pressure
necessarily. It's just gravity. Um, if
it was under pressure, I wouldn't turn
it on. But let's see what happens here.
Let's give it a try.
[Music]
While that tank is filling up, let me
show you what we got going on here and
uh this whole setup and why I did what I
did and what the future plans are. We'll
start up here at the ditch. Um, this is
what's known as an irrigation ditch.
It's a part of a large network of
ditches throughout the uh county here
and they go into other counties and
stuff like that and it just gets water
from one place to the other. Luckily, it
goes right through our property. Um, you
do have to pay for it, which is what
this box is. You notice there's a lock
on one side and then an opening on the
other.
Basically, get in there, clean out the
screen side, and then on this side,
they took it out.
But there's a piece of plywood typically
that goes in there like this.
I think they were having a hard time
getting the old one out, so they just
kind of walked away. But that plywood
slides in
down there like so. And this is how much
water I'm supposed to be getting. A half
3/4 of an inch. But right now, I'm
getting full ditch. So, I'm not going to
complain. It'll fill it up. If they
forget to swap it out, that's okay with
me.
Then
on the end of that box inside is a pipe.
4-in pipe. comes through the ground here
and pops out right here.
At the end of that pipe is this valve
and that allows me to control and shut
off the water there. One thing that uh
when I was plumbing this all up, I
noticed that that
male male slipped fitting here was not
really what I wanted. I should have
replaced it, but I didn't. And now you
can see it's leaking. So, if you should
replace, you should replace.
Anyway, I did a 4 inch little pipe here
to get me out and then a four to three
reducer, three to inch and a half
reducer. Little inch and a half pipe
running up here. Uh, the reason I went
inch and a half is the
um
what do they call it? Not petcock. Uh
the fitting here I'll remember in the
tank here was inch and a half. So I just
figured might as well do full port all
the way through. Um male slip thread
here 90 down. Um I did put a shut off
here um below one because I could use
the water
without the tank if I need and also I
could use it as a cleanout. You'll
notice when I first fired it up, I left
this open so that anything that was in
that pipe, although I did run it before
I put all this on there, anything that
was in that pipe would kind of clean out
and drop out the bottom. What's that?
So, now
we're filling up the tank.
It's only been running for about half an
hour and it's almost full. So, I think
might be a pretty quick fill.
Uh, this is the tank. Pretty simple,
self-explanatory.
I did just level out an area for it, set
it down. I did put wood chips underneath
it just to give any voids, fill the
voids and stuff like that. Um, so yeah,
that's just that,00.
Uh, the reason I went with a smaller
tank is because I needed to be lower
than the ditch. And if I would have went
with like a 2500gallon tank, I would
have been my out my inlet would have
been like 7 or 8 ft up in the air. So I
just decided we'll go little and if I
need to, I can add another tank, you
know, next to it or something like that.
But I think this should be fine. Um then
we'll come down to the
lower valves here.
Uh I went with 2 in only because the
existing
it's not ballcohawk
manifold. I forget the existing fitting
here was 2 in. So I just decided to keep
it full port all the way through. I did
run two valves because I have a hard
time making decisions.
So this gives me options later in the
future because I'd have to drain the
whole tank in order to put another valve
in. So I can do something here later.
also irrigate the field if I need to.
Same with kind of this thing. And then
on this valve, being as it's the
straight shooter coming right out of the
tank, I I won't have any turbulence
issues here. So, this will just come
right out. What I did is just a 2-in
slip to male thread or slip to female
thread. And that
again because I can't make my mind up or
decisions allows me to do different
things. So 2 in to inch and a quarter,
inch and a quarter to 1 in. And that
just allows me to
adjust whatever I want to put on this at
all times. My next goal is to figure out
how to get it from the tank
to the garden. So, coming up, the next
videos will be different things. Uh, gas
powered pump, possibly a solar well pump
if it ever comes. Uh, I did get drip
irrigation, a low PSI drip irrigation. I
also want to see what the PSI is on this
tank with a garden hose over here. Just
see how much PSI I have. If I have
enough, I won't need to do any sort of
pumps. So, that'll work out great. So,
keep an eye out for those videos. Thanks
for watching. We'll see you on the next
one.